l'accord dans l'enceinte sacrée des lois
canadiennes la justice aura bientôt un
nouveau visage et pour la première fois
il ne sera pas blanc mahmoud jamal
originaire du kenya diplômé de
l'université mcgill et juge à la cour
d'appel de l'ontario revêtira bientôt la
toge rouge d'apparat une première pour
un juge issus de la diversité
il est bilingue c'est une excellente
nouvelle pour la communauté francophone
également pour la communauté des
minorités visibles route n'est respectée
dans la communauté juridique
un avocat d'un haut calibre âgé de 54
ans qui a déjà plaidé 35 fois devant la
cour suprême
c'est un concert nalistes très bien
respecté qui a écrit longuement sur
plusieurs décisions
il est également quelqu'un qui est
reconnu pour les dossiers complexes au
niveau civil et commercial
il était temps lens est avocat
autochtone que le plus haut tribunal du
pays reflète davantage la diversité
canadienne avoir un juge qui a lui même
vécu du racisme selon lui apportera un
nouvel éclairage à la cour suprême
notamment dans les contestations à venir
sur les peines minimales qui envoie en
prison un nombre disproportionné de
personnes noires ou autochtone une
nomination bien accueillie par le juge
en chef de la cour suprême qui plaide
lui même depuis plusieurs années pour
une plus grande diversité judiciaire moi
des gens qui sont tous pareils qui
pensent toutes pareilles qui ont la même
éducation je pense pas qu'on puisse
parler d'une justice adéquate dans une
société pluraliste comme la nôtre on
serait dans une société de céramique
justin trudeau n'avait pas le choix de
combler ce siège à la cour suprême avant
l'été puisque la juge rosalie abella
prend sa retraite le 1er juillet une
autre nomination très attendu avant de
possibles élections et celles du
prochain gouverneur général ce qui
pourrait avoir lieu avant la fin du mois
et si christian noël radio canada ottawa